I want to talk to you about this the
Chip and Dales project because that's
coming out in I think it's a week now
yeah next week November you've worked
really hard on this and this is based on
a true story
yeah so the show is called Welcome to
Chippendales it's based on the guy who
started Chippendales the mail stripping
thing was an Indian immigrant uh which I
didn't know until I started you know
until they they talked to me about this
project and um it's a wild story like a
lot of really intense stuff happened
people people got murdered it was it's
like a really crazy it's it's a it's
it's just so much happens in it that I
don't want to say and don't go on
Wikipedia watch the show
um and initially you know they'd come to
me as a movie right after the big thing
came out to like five years ago four
years ago
and I said no because I was very
intimidated to play a character like
this and then
anyone that came back and that was a
mini series
I sort of saw the whole thing they
pitched me the you know it's Rob Siegel
is the creator of it he did Pam and
Tommy he's written a lot of great movies
like The Wrestler he did big fan have
you seen that movie with Patton
fantastic great writer
and uh I talked to him three or four
times and he was trying he was like I
think you can do this and then he
pitched me the on the fourth meeting he
pitched me every episode all Eight
Episodes he's like this is what happens
in episode two episode three and I was
like this is just too cool to not do I
have to do it and I just have to figure
out how to not be scared of it anymore
you know and uh
and it was it was really really the most
satisfying professional experience I've
had since making the big sex really I
really felt like I one you know it's
interesting because I've worked with a
lot of uh actors who come from the
comedy world and so when you work with
people who come from the other angle
from theater from like you know serious
acting school we may end up in the same
place but they come from a completely
different uh perspective the way they
approach acting it's so exciting to work
with people like that because
comedy can be competitive you know even
when I'm doing a stand-up show with my
best friends I want to be the best on
that show
that's not the job of like theater
actors they want to make you better they
want to be there with you they want to
collaborate with you and you've done a
lot of collaborative comedy I started in
stand up it's not collaborative at all
it's competitive and then on this show
working with Murray Bartlett and Anna
Lee Ashford who are like two of the best
actors I have ever worked with I learned
so much from them there was something I
was doing in a scene in episode seven
and I was like oh I learned that from
Murray back in episode two so it's like
every day you're working with these
people
who are the best you've ever worked with
and you're learning so much every day
and for the first time ever I had like
oh I'm having trouble with this scene
and I would go to like the my my
co-stars and be like hey I'm having
trouble with this team could you like
help me through it and we'd sit on the
floor and they'd like
we'd like work on it together it was so
exciting it was the most fun uh I've had
at a job in a very long time I have to
say there's this way that
um our business or whatever our business
is but television
particularly has changed so much and
we're in this era now where there's
eight episodes you know yeah and
um I'm really think it's a great
uh it's a great Trend it's a great
Innovation because as you know TV used
to be can you get Five Seasons out of it
and yes um and
it used to be in the really old days can
you get 10 seasons out of it and can you
just flog this horse until it dies yes
and uh now there are all these projects
where people work really hard as hard or
harder than they would work on any
feature film
they look great they're beautifully made
and they take you on this journey that's
like an eight-hour journey and everybody
gets pulled into it and you watch it uh
you you follow it you get really
invested and when it's over it's very
satisfying I like this new era of
Television yeah and honestly like our
crew you know wardrobe hair makeup
um set design props everybody was like
the best in the business and really
wanted to be really really good so the
show looks amazing
um our DP everybody's amazing and the
the big thing for me going from doing
like sitcoms to this is you know sitcoms
are sort of about stasis you're sort of
resetting like you were talking about
Silicon Valley once we figure out our
characters that's the formula and you're
sort of doing that iterating that in
different ways doing a mini series is
about change yes it's really about how
these characters change over eight
episodes the approach is very different
you know with Silicon Valley I could get
a script and do it with this
you really have to kind of map out all
Eight Episodes
um where the changes are the different
decision points the forks in the road
which which side you know
which which side you choose which side
you go uh so it sounds like a very
different approach and it's it's really
more exciting because you can kind of
it's not more exciting I love doing
comedy actually we we did
um
uh you're in murderville yeah I love
doing that show so much wasn't that fun
it was so fun because I just missed
being like all you have to do is be as
funny as possible for these 30 and and
re react and react yeah uh yeah Will
Arnett I'm sure you know with you he's
called up and just said I want to do
this project where you don't know
anything
um you're a police trainee and uh you
were going to enter scenes and not know
what's happening and just respond and I
had people say to me later on oh that
must have been terrifying and I said oh
no no no no no no no no there's nothing
greater then having no responsibility
yes uh and and also I mean it's Will
Arnett and he's got all these other
really he's so brilliantly fun so funny
but he got he's so much fun to play with
you can't [ __ ] up because I have no
lines there's nothing I'm supposed to or
not supposed to do so then the little
child in you comes out yeah and
um you're just down with anything it's
just say yes to anything yeah uh and it
was so much fun uh but you're right
there are these different ways now to
work and not just in comedy but there
are these different ways now to
um entertain I think that weren't
available
young people don't know this but they
weren't available 10 years ago I think
to me the big change without getting
like too analytical is
Breaking Bad was a TV show
um it wasn't a sitcom but it was a TV
show that uh kept
I mean more brilliantly than I think it
had ever been done before uh it it
characters are all changing very slowly
over this I don't remember how season
how many seasons it is is it eight
seasons seven seven it's six seasons
over six seasons
the vision that Vince Gilligan had to
he always said he wanted to take
um
the main character uh Walt he wanted him
to go from Mr Chips
you know the English school teacher to
Scarface
but and and do it so elegantly that you
never questioned any step in the any
step along the way and he pulled it off
but you can't Define where it all
changes you just it's so incremental
that by the time it was over you
understood completely why this had all
happened yet it's an insane Journey
um and I think now that that uh
you know the TV I grew up with was
very much everything whatever happens in
an episode at the end of the episode
everyone has to be back where they were
at the beginning of the episode right
that was the rule of sitcoms it's like
the Gilligan's Island at the end of the
episode they have to still be on the
island and content with their lot in
life and then we'll start the next one
yeah whatever lesson they've learned
they'll have forgotten by the time the
next episode starts it's totally true we
really took that to the extreme on The
Simpsons
occasionally
the top brass would come in and say
you're making Homer too stupid yeah he
he forgets how to breathe at one point
at one point he forgets how to make his
heart beat
and my favorite and they used to come in
and say like guys guys come on because
we would try to outdo each other in the
writer's room about how stupid we could
make Homer and my favorite was once
Homer's brain got so mad at Homer that
it walked out on him
I don't even know what that means but
there's a point where Homer said Homer's
brain challenges him to not to something
stupid and he still does something
stupid and you hear Homer's
Consciousness go okay that does it and
then you hear footsteps and a door slam
which means his Consciousness left him
forever through a door well see that's
great
those shows does a joy to them you know
like
those comedy shows I love the show
Seinfeld everybody stays the same those
shows are amazing it's just now it's a
different type of thing like different
type of thing Breaking Bad is the kind
of the best example we're just watching
Better Call Saul for the first time oh
it's so great it's so good and you know
sometimes I think I always think you
know Breaking Bad is like a serious show
I think of these serious shows as being
serious they're not they're like really
fun and inventive and funny and I mean
Sopranos is really really funny I sort
of forget that sometimes but that was
what was cool about welcome to
Chippendales was trying to do that Arc
and like every episode figuring out
where the little steps are so that it
all makes sense and the guy in the
beginning at the end
they're completely different